what is going on there reject nation so
all this stuff behind us but packing
right now because i just got a new place
we got a move this week and uh it's
gonna hopefully nothing too massive
drops so that way we can be around for
it but uh yeah you know we're gonna
about to shoot the stranger things
finale getting all the recordings out of
the way and apparently we are close to a
million subscribers and we'll let you
know if we're gonna do a live stream
we've got to get a lot of packing done
because we got to get out of here but i
mean to have come this far uh even just
being close to a million right now means
the world
uh just looking back on this whole crazy
journey so thank you guys and someone
say thank you in advance
and yeah maybe we'll do a countdown
tonight if if there's time uh maybe
something tomorrow but just wanted to
say thank you even before the big
numbers came this way keep a lookout for
the rest of our stranger things
reactions too as we're chipping away at
them